pour être honnête on les avait un peu
oublié ces élections municipales de juin
dernier
l'actualité ayant été vampirisée par la
crise du coc vide 19
cela fait donc huit mois que le scrutin
s'est achevé et c'est le temps qu'il
aura fallu pour que les résultats
complets par tendances politiques soient
dévoilés la vue d'ensemble est riche en
enseignements
on constate d'abord sans grande surprise
le fort ancrage local de la droite et
dans une moindre mesure de la gauche et
le chiffre le plus impressionnant est
sans doute le score réalisé par le parti
présidentiel
la république en marche a recueilli au
total 2,22 % des suffrages lors de ces
élections municipales un sacré revers
pour le parti majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale qui n'a visiblement pas
converti sa percée nationale lors de ce
scrutin local et même si les candidats
centristes au sens large s'en sortent
mieux
cela ne suffit pas à masquer la déroute
de la république en marche alors ce
chiffre peu glorieux explique-t-il la
lenteur de publication des résultats
officiels par le ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est une possibilité selon olivier marc
l'ex député les républicains d'eure et
loir c'est lui qui a pressé le ministre
de l'intérieur de lui fournir enfin les
résultats officiels en voyant ces
chiffres où est l'erreur matin seulement
2 22% sous ses propres couleurs on
comprend bien pourquoi le pouvoir n'est
pas pressé de les diffuser
en réalité cela révèle l'échec d'un
ancrage politique qui ne parvient pas à
bousculer le paysage local échec
prévisible et attendu y compris par la
majorité présidentielle rappelons nous
que quelques mois avant le scrutin
christophe castaner alors ministre de
l'intérieur avait publié une circulaire
afin de demander au préfet de ne pas
attribuer de nuances politiques aux
listes qui se présentait dans les
communes de moins de 9000 habitants
une mesure qui aurait concerné 97% des
communes est circulaire avait finalement
été suspendu par le conseil d'état à la
suite de recours de plusieurs élus
d'opposition qui voyait là une stratégie
politicienne visant à dissimuler la
débâcle à venir
pour le parti présidentiel le robert a
donc bien eu lieu et il est désormais
visible par tous il convient toutefois
de nuancer ce faible score les élections
municipales sont assez différentes des
scrutins nationaux et leur taux
d'abstention s'est élevé à plus de 58%
de quoi relativiser un peu ces mauvais
résultats restent car à quelques mois
des élections régionales et
départementales qui ont d'ailleurs été
reporté et un peu plus d'un an de
l'élection présidentielle ce chiffre
peut être perçu comme un avertissement